hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cod now I know
a lot of you have been wanting to me to
play a co D for a while so here I am
with the most realistic god
fighting simulator there is let's do
this
chum the waters a reliable tip from the
NOAA says that there may be broke God's
soldiers deployed in this area search
the force and search for any signs of
them if you find any who have an
authorization to engage on site when you
finish report back here via the laptop
stay frosty
da-da-da-da-da-da-da
I gotta find these Cod and slaughter
them where they stand close oh look oh
no I'm out of ammo got it get my pistol
out no I've got plenty of ammo actually
let's see where's my where's my rocket
there start it her ugh wait reload gotta
reload one run this 12 fish remaining
out in these woods
gotta get a move yeah I do I like this
rock rock brood
oh sweet 360 rocket launcher noscope oh
god I'm great I'm so great okay well the
cod are now dead and I can report back
god I hope I rank up after this uh good
miss dammit I should have known those
damn water breathers were out there good
work soldier
clean up and return to base what was
that noise
Oh Misha do noodlin the clues we found
in the forest indicate that the scaly
scum are holed up at these barracks take
out any of them take out any of them out
in the forest and the rest should come
running right those damn fish they kill
my best friend
obviously these noobs don't know what's
up thank you come again neither where's
my rocket launchers that's what I really
need my friend a family y'all the
fishing the barracks gladly I see
dandelo dandelo
none will survive my own son now ah here
they get me I like the pistol better
than the machine gun
I'm obviously too proud for these fish
to handle sneaking up all over them
there any in here nope but there are
barrels the barrels must be destroyed
oh I love the rocket launcher there we
go got them all up
wait one left get the plans off the
computer of right mission nearly
accomplished just gotta get the plans
see Mother of God they plan on
destroying the town I'll get these plans
to Central Command at once you get out
of there at once and report back to me
they've said noise again what is that
mr. three schools of thought the attack
is imminent we've done our best to clear
the town of civilians get in there and
send all those bastards to the spawning
pool good luck soldier got you some fish
wait what is this just imagine good
driver no I know right boom no there we
go boom boom reloading fish oh no my
mother ran out of ammo I'll have just
enough to destroy these bastards these
wet bastards don't know what they're
talking about good job that was only the
first wave though catch your breath and
wait for the counter-attack don'tdon't
on the counter-attack of more barrels
appearing okay
down garden fest you think you could
sneak up on me just like you did filling
bub families they had families had you
slaughtered them in there while they
were not sleeping but they were standing
there and they were killing all your
friends but how could you kill them you
found God bastards yeah yeah I feel like
this would be a lot better with some
more like dramatic music playing or
something at least but no I guess this
is fine I like the way to thank load
into scaled I guess I should do some I
don't know commentary or something on
this game since that what that's what I
pretend to be a professional gaming
commentator I must say that in compared
to the realism and gritty realism of
normal college education this one really
steps it up I mean there was black ops
of course and then those modern warfare
with this this truly is the epitome of
fish fighting simulators I mean I
actually feel I actually feel like I'm
there back in world war fish um and
where it was really really really gritty
I mean this really understands the
sacrifices that the soldiers made go
tell push back the cod menace and now
today everyone all boys and girls around
the nation can enjoy a nice Cod dinner
in memory of the peace talks of 1985 boy
those were rough times I'm glad I'm born
in a world where fish and men could get
along together but right now goddamn
soldier you are a one-man fist killing
machine hunker down the last wave is on
the move wait what's that up in the sky
catch the fish this big I don't care
what it is what it takes
bring that down I guess I'll have to use
this
your fish bastard your bastard I'll
destroy you whatever it takes we're a
date do you think you can drop troops on
me I actually like turn this mother out
and hang on I like to put hang on
yeah I'm curious is there is there a
single video that I can go through
without screaming my head off or is that
just a thing that I do now
died already there we go it's no good
the firepower you've got isn't enough
we're gonna have to nuke it from orbit
it's the only way to be sure use the
laptop in the center of town to call in
the strike and soldier thank you for my
family from filling Bob for Bharti and
Bremen
I did it for my family my friends for
your grand deeds against the amphibious
threats to our nation you have been
forever remembered in this commemorative
coin by the Franklin Mint
congratulations I did it for my country
alright okay anyway so that was call of
duty thou satisfy all of you people
clamoring for me to play God and so I
hope you enjoyed it it was an immersive
and just the emotions that I felt as I
was like in the shoes of an actual Cod
fighter I I couldn't believe it the
graphics were amazing
like absolutely incredible I can't
believe what they can push on today's
consoles it's just absolutely incredibly
and the story just putting it together
in the like I can't believe you know
when when it was first done where the
main character dies I was just it was so
heart wrenching to me and this one
really pulled the wool over my eyes when
it did it twice and not then twice and
then a third time where the sacrifice
was made by the person himself oh oh man
unbelievable unbelievable absolutely
incredible I couldn't I could not
understand how they managed to trick me
a third time into thinking that I was
gonna survive but the it felt like I was
making that sacrifice a part of me died
each time the main character died so oh
it's so touching it it's so good to know
that people can make games like this
nowadays without going on the same
repetitive routine or they can you know
I mean it is stimbler but they can bring
life to it okay
I'm rambling now so I'm gonna get done
it kind of 10 oh man so great so click
the link in the description below to
play for yourselves thank you all so
much for watching click the end of ASA 4
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
Wow